Карпати
Луквиця
Відчуття польоту не можна описати.
Навіть якщо його хтось може описати для себе,
то для когось іншого воно буде не таким.
І кожний бере від цього своє.
Це злітна смуга - 500 метрів довжина,
висота 560 м над рівнем моря.
Це найвищий
злітно-посадочний майданчик в Україні.
Найвисокогірніший аеродром в Україні.
На мою думку, мінімум у кожному районі
має бути аеродром.
Навіть якщо якась стихія, або щось інше.
Щоб можна було дістатися до населених пунктів.
В Америці у кожному поважаючому себе місті
є свій аеродром.
Якби ми мали у кожному районі -
було б дуже круто.
Вмикаємо генератори, оці штуки,
запускаємо правий двигун.
Щоб навчитися літати в принципі, для підготовки приватного пілота,
за міжнародними стандартами,
передбачено від 40 годин.
Це треба політати не на тренажері,
щоб отримати ліцензію.
Це взагалі така свобода!
Ти можеж
за дівками подивитися, курей побудити.
Ми закохалися у небо,
Нам тільки крила мати треба,
Щоби полинути до хмар,
Де є так любо й мило нам.
Кохання білі крила,
Лечу до тебе мила,
Із гір із полонин!
Несу тобі в дарунки
Гарячі поцілунки
І з ними неба синь!
Я, як і багато людей,
люблю авіацію.
У дитинстві я пас корів.
Поруч була груша,
я виліз на ту грушу і пообрізав на ній зайві гілки, бо думав, що так має бути.
І то для мене був літак! Я був на висоті.
А корови були у долині.
Я собі там уявно літав.
У 1978 році
я збудував перший дерев'яний дельтаплан.
Раніше, у 1974 році,
був побудований перший дельтаплан у Радянському Союзі.
У 1993 році знайомі
запросили мене показати пластунам,
що таке авіамоделі і дельтаплани.
Вони приїхали до Луквиці.
Я показав моделі,
а потім треба було полетіти на дельтаплані.
Ми поїхали до сусіднього села Крички,
там є хребет, скала 80 метрів.
Вертикальна скала
і хребет 300 метрів.
Мені віднесли туди дельтаплан
і я звідти полетів.
Літав поки вся група йшла вниз.
Мене попросили,
аби я їм допомагав в організації табору.
Мені сподобалась методика
виховання молоді
і сама ідея.
Кажу: хлопці давайте зробимо
базу для виховання молоді.
Одна умова - це має бути авіаційний напрям.
Я вирішив,
що решту життя
я присвячу для цієї справи.
Так з'явився табір "Чота Крилатих".
Кожного року ми робимо табір для пластунів.
Для біля 20-30 людей.
Не лише, щоб вчитися,
але і ознайомитися з технікою пароплану
чи дельтаплану.
Намагаються літати.
Я називаю це "Air-Camping",
відпочинково-тренувальна база
авіаційного напряму.
Щоб ви могли приїхати відпочити
і політати.
Взагалі найкраще буде,
коли люди прилетять на своєму літальному апараті.
У нас дуже багато хлопців пішли до льотного училища.
Серед вихованців військові льотчики
і командири ескадрильї,
СУ-27, МІ-29.
Взагалі, з пластунами вже навіть не я працюю.
Зараз їх навчають хлопці і дівчата,
яких я вчив.
Вони навіть вже літають,
можуть провети початкову підготовку з пароплану.
Тішуся, що є люди,
які краще від мене літають.
Я ніколи не ставив собі за мету
стати чудовим паропланерним спортсменом.
Просто хочу навчити людину,
щоб вона потім не наробила дурниць, це моя основна мета.
Я щасливий!
Немає нічого кращого,
ніж бачити реакцію того, хто тішиться від польоту.
Власне заради цього
варто займатися.
Адже це така щира втіха,
яку неможливо вдавати.
Ну то не можна підробити, коли людина
щаслива від того, що вона нарешті політала.
Субтитри - Владислав Цовма.